selamat datang kembali di Quantum Computing in Practice, aku Olivia Lan dan episode tiga hari ini akan fokus pada
eksperimen qaoa di skala utilitas kalau kamu udah ikutin dari awal, kamu udah lihat kita bahas
IBM Quantum Hardware, framework Qiskit patterns, dan teknik mitigasi error terbaru dan terbaik yang
dipakai para peneliti dan developer untuk scale up Quantum circuit kita rasa penting banget kasih semua konteks ini
dan tunjukin arah yang kita tuju tapi sekarang nggak ada alasan lagi untuk nunggu lebih lama melihat semua info ini dalam
aksi sekarang ada beberapa hal yang perlu diingat sebelum kita mulai, semuanya bakal mengikuti framework Qiskit
patterns jadi kita bakal lewati langkah-langkah ini secara urut, nomor satu adalah memetakan masalah, dua mengoptimalkan circuit, tiga
mengeksekusi dengan Primitives, dan empat post-processing atau menganalisis hasilnya kita mulai dengan contoh yang cukup kecil
supaya kalian semua bisa paling mudah memahami langkah-langkah ini dan tujuannya lalu kita akan bahas contoh yang sangat mirip tapi jauh
lebih besar untuk menunjukkan bagaimana cara scale up masalah ke level 100 qubit aku bakal kasih kalian semua
tools supaya kalian bisa lanjut setelah kuliah ini dan menjalankan masalah itu secara mandiri terakhir, ini nggak bakal jadi
walkthrough kode, seberapa pun kita berusaha, seiring kita maju kode jadi usang dan deprecated, jadi kalau kamu
nonton video ini setahun setelah rilis, aku nggak mau kamu terjebak pada sintaks yang mungkin sedikit berubah seiring waktu, jadi ini bakal jadi
diskusi mendetail tentang logika dan pernyataan masalah tapi ada tutorial notebook yang berpasangan dengan
video ini yang dilampirkan di deskripsi di bawah, mengikuti kodenya atau merujuk ke sana setelah kamu
nonton pelajaran ini dan menjalankannya sendiri akan memberi kamu pengalaman belajar terbaik, jadi sebagai pengingat singkat,
nggak semua masalah komputasi cocok untuk Quantum Computing, masalah mudah dan perhitungan sederhana nggak perlu memanfaatkan
teknologi ini karena komputer klasik udah sangat bagus dalam menyelesaikannya, per 2024
tiga domain yang paling kita optimis untuk dieksplorasi adalah ini: mensimulasikan alam, memproses data dengan struktur
kompleks, dan terakhir optimasi, masalah optimasi adalah beberapa masalah komputasi
yang paling sulit diselesaikan secara efisien, dalam masalah optimasi kamu mencari nilai terbesar atau terkecil yang mungkin
untuk fungsi biaya tertentu, tapi untuk banyak masalah yang menarik, menemukan ekstremum ini menjadi semakin eksponensial lebih
sulit seiring ukuran masalah, itulah kenapa jadi sangat sulit untuk dihitung, sebagai contoh kamu bisa bayangkan betapa
sulitnya menghitung jalur penerbangan optimal atau rute pengiriman di seluruh negeri, dalam pelajaran ini kita akan
mengeksplorasi masalah optimasi tertentu yang disebut Max cut, yang akan kita selesaikan dengan menggunakan algoritma Quantum
yang disebut quantum approximation optimization algorithm atau qaoa, jadi apa itu masalah max cut? masalah
maximum cut adalah jenis masalah optimasi kombinatorial yang didefinisikan pada sebuah graph di mana tujuannya adalah
mempartisi simpul-simpul graph menjadi dua subset sedemikian rupa sehingga jumlah sisi antara dua subset tersebut
dimaksimalkan, jadi misalnya dalam graph ini setiap node terhubung seperti ini dan max cut ditunjukkan oleh garis berlekuk ini
yang membagi node menjadi grup ungu dan grup abu-abu, cara melakukannya dengan melewati jumlah
sisi terbanyak yang mungkin adalah memotong melalui lima sisi, untuk graph ini karena graph-nya sangat kecil
nggak susah untuk mencoba beberapa potongan yang mungkin di atas kertas atau bahkan di kepala kamu dan mencari tahu bahwa lima adalah kemungkinan terbaik
tapi bayangkan kalau jumlah node berlipat ganda dan kemudian tiga kali lipat, dengan cepat ini menjadi tidak mungkin dilakukan
secara manual dan setelah jumlah tertentu jadi sangat sulit sehingga bahkan superkomputer pun kesulitan untuk mengembalikan jawaban terbaik secara andal, ini karena
jumlah maksimum potongan bertambah secara eksponensial dengan jumlah node, meskipun ini terlihat agak abstrak
ada banyak masalah dunia nyata yang bisa diubah menjadi masalah Max cut seperti deteksi penipuan di keuangan,
clustering graph, desain jaringan, desain VLSI, juga analisis media sosial,
yang media sosial sangat mudah dipahami, misalnya kamu ingin menemukan sekelompok individu yang memiliki koneksi sebanyak mungkin
ke individu lain di platform media sosial, untuk mengidentifikasi power user atau orang yang memiliki
pengaruh paling besar dalam sebuah grup, perusahaan sebenarnya cukup sering mencoba melakukan ini, satu poin terakhir di sini, max cut sering kali
merupakan subrutin dari masalah yang lebih besar, jadi mungkin bukan mendefinisikan aplikasi sebenarnya tapi digunakan di balik layar, ini
jauh lebih umum dari yang mungkin kamu bayangkan secara naif, sekarang waktunya untuk memulai,
langkah pertama adalah membuat graph kamu, kamu bisa melakukan ini dengan mengimpor paket Python yang disebut rustworks, tentukan berapa
banyak node yang kamu kerjakan dengan menentukan angka n, lalu tambahkan node kamu ke graph G, kamu juga harus
menggambar sisi-sisimu, kita lakukan ini secara manual di sini dengan hanya mencantumkannya dalam sebuah array seperti ini di mana kamu menunjukkan
angka terakhir yang menentukan bobot sisi atau seberapa kuat dua node yang ditentukan terhubung, di sini kita hanya
akan menggunakan bobot satu untuk semua tapi kamu mungkin senang bermain-main dengan bobot nanti dan melihat bagaimana solusi
berubah, untuk mendapatkan gambaran tentang apa arti bobot dalam konteks ini, mari kita kembali ke contoh media sosial kita, kamu bisa berpikir
tentang bobot ini sebagai seberapa berpengaruh satu orang mungkin terhadap orang lain, koneksi kamu ke pasangan atau kerabat
misalnya mungkin akan diberi bobot yang lebih tinggi daripada seseorang yang hanya kenalan, sekarang gambar graph kamu,
tutorial yang terlampir akan menunjukkan sintaks yang tepat terlebih dahulu sebelum mempertimbangkan bagaimana cara
memetakan masalah ini ke Quantum circuit, mari kita bangun beberapa konteks tentang bagaimana masalah max cut menjadi masalah optimasi
sejak awal, kita mulai dengan terlebih dahulu mempertimbangkan minimasi fungsi f dari x di mana input x adalah
vektor berdimensi-n yang komponennya sesuai dengan setiap node dalam graph, kita akan menyebut fungsi ini mulai sekarang
sebagai fungsi biaya kita, lalu kita perlu membatasi masing-masing komponen ini menjadi nol atau
satu di sini, artinya di satu sisi potongan atau yang lainnya, kita bisa menulis sebuah fungsi sebagai
sepasang node x i dan XJ yang memberi tahu kita apakah Sisi yang sesuai ada dalam potongan, sehingga ditambah kuantitas x i + XJ
dikurangi x i XJ mengidentifikasi apakah sisi ada dalam potongan, kalau kuantitas ini sama dengan
satu, ini berarti sisi ada dalam potongan, jika tidak maka nol dan sisi tidak ada, masalah menemukan
jumlah sisi maksimum dalam potongan kemudian bisa dirumuskan sebagai memaksimalkan fungsi ini, selanjutnya kita sebenarnya akan
menambahkan tanda minus global ke fungsi ini sehingga masalah baru setara dengan menemukan minimum dari fungsi ini
WEBVTT
sebagai gantinya dan jadi minimum dari f dari x dalam kasus ini akan terjadi ketika jumlah sisi yang dilintasi oleh potongan adalah
maksimal, kita memilih untuk merumuskan masalah ini sebagai masalah minimasi karena ini memungkinkan kita nanti memetakannya ke masalah
minimasi energi alias mencari ground state, yang memang sangat bagus dilakukan oleh komputer kuantum secara alami
tapi ingat belum ada yang berkaitan dengan Quantum Computing di sini, kita masih perlu merumuskan ulang masalah ini menjadi
sesuatu yang bisa dipahami oleh komputer kuantum, kita sekarang siap untuk mulai bekerja dan
langkah pertama adalah memetakan masalah ke Quantum circuit, mungkin tidak jelas bagaimana kita
akan beralih dari graph seperti yang baru kita gambar ke Quantum circuit tapi mari kita perlahan ingat kita
akan mencoba menyelesaikan masalah Max cut ini menggunakan qaoa, dalam algoritma qaoa kita pada akhirnya ingin memiliki operator
yaitu hamiltonian yang akan digunakan untuk merepresentasikan fungsi biaya dari masalah kita serta
circuit yang diparameterisasi, ansatz atau trial state yang akan kita gunakan untuk merepresentasikan state kuantum yang merupakan tebakan terdidik atau kandidat
untuk solusi masalah, kita bisa mengambil sampel dari state kandidat ini dan kemudian mengevaluasinya
menggunakan fungsi biaya, dalam kasus ini fungsi biayanya adalah f dari x tapi kita perlu mengekspresikannya dalam
cara yang terasa alami bagi komputer kuantum, untuk ini kita akan memanfaatkan serangkaian transformasi matematis
untuk mengekspresikan f dari x sebagai fungsi energi yaitu hamiltonian, langkah pertama dari
proses ini adalah mengekspresikan masalah minimasi f dari x sebagai quadratic unconstrained binary optimization
problem atau QUBO untuk singkatnya, QUBO adalah cara umum untuk merumuskan masalah optimasi kombinatorial ini
di sini Q adalah matriks N kali N dari bilangan real, n sesuai dengan jumlah
node dalam graph kita, lima untuk contoh ini, dan X adalah vektor yang sama dari variabel biner dari
formulasi awal, untuk menjalankan algoritma qaoa secara efektif kita perlu mengekspresikan masalah optimasi kita dalam hal
hamiltonian, yang merupakan operator matematis yang merepresentasikan total energi suatu sistem, khususnya kita ingin
membuat hamiltonian fungsi biaya yang memiliki sifat bahwa energi ground state-nya atau nilai eigen minimum
sesuai dengan minimum dari fungsi yang mengkodekan jumlah maksimum potongan pada graph g, setelah kita
memiliki hamiltonian ini, yang perlu kita lakukan untuk menyelesaikan masalah optimasi adalah mempersiapkan ground state dari hamiltonian di komputer kuantum, lalu
mengambil sampel dari state ini akan dengan probabilitas tinggi menghasilkan solusi untuk minimasi dari f dari X, ternyata
kita beruntung karena masalah QUBO sangat erat kaitannya dengan dan sebenarnya secara komputasi setara dengan
salah satu hamiltonian paling terkenal dan tersebar luas dalam fisika yaitu hamiltonian Ising, untuk menulis masalah QUBO
sebagai hamiltonian Ising ini, yang sebenarnya perlu kita lakukan hanyalah perubahan variabel sederhana untuk beralih dari
variabel Boolean 0 dan 1 ke variabel spin minus satu dan satu, langkah ini
mudah, ditunjukkan secara lebih rinci di appendix dari notebook yang terlampir bagi yang tertarik, tapi pada akhirnya minimasi dari ekspresi QUBO ini
sama dengan minimasi dari ekspresi ini, dengan menulis ulang lagi sedikit dan
kita punya hamiltonian fungsi biaya kita di mana minimum ekspresi merepresentasikan ground state dan Z
menjadi operator Pauli sementara B adalah koefisien skalar real, setelah kita punya hamiltonian
kita, mudah untuk menulisnya ulang dalam hal dua operator ZZ Pauli lokal yang akan mudah dikonversi menjadi
dua gate RZZI dalam Quantum circuit kita, silakan lihat notebook yang terkait untuk melihat bagaimana ini dilakukan tapi outputnya
diberikan oleh baris ini, perhatikan bahwa dalam contoh kita ada
enam objek atau string Pauli karena masing-masing merepresentasikan sebuah sisi dalam graph, panjang string sesuai dengan jumlah
node jadi I I I ZZ adalah lima node dan string akan terdiri dari
identitas di semua posisi kecuali untuk indeks node yang terlibat dalam sebuah sisi yang akan memiliki suku Z, dalam Qiskit
bit string yang merepresentasikan qubit diindeks secara terbalik, misalnya sisi antara node 0 dan 1 akan dikodekan sebagai
I I I ZZ, dengan hamiltonian yang ditulis dalam hal Pauli, kita siap untuk membangun
Quantum circuit kita, Quantum circuit ini akan membantu kita mengambil sampel solusi yang bagus dari komputer kuantum, algoritma qaoa
terinspirasi dari teori adiabatik yang menyatakan bahwa jika kita mulai di ground state dari
hamiltonian yang bergantung waktu dan jika hamiltonian berevolusi cukup lambat dan diberi waktu yang cukup, state akhir akan menjadi ground
state dari hamiltonian akhir, qaoa bisa dianggap sebagai versi Trotter diskret dari algoritma
adiabatik kuantum di mana setiap langkah Trotter merepresentasikan sebuah layer yang akan kita sebut P, jadi
alih-alih berevolusi dari satu state ke yang lain, dalam setiap layer P kita akan berganti-ganti antara fungsi biaya
kita dan sesuatu yang disebut mixer hamiltonian kita, yang akan kita dengar lebih lanjut sebentar lagi, tapi poin yang ingin aku sampaikan
adalah bahwa qaoa memiliki keunggulan lebih cepat dari algoritma adiabatik kuantum tapi mengembalikan solusi yang
approksimasi daripada yang optimal, dalam batas di mana jumlah layer mendekati tak terhingga, qaoa konvergen ke kasus
adiabatik tapi tentu saja ini sangat mahal secara komputasi, untuk membuat Quantum circuit kita
kita akan menerapkan operator bergantian di sini yang diparameterisasi oleh gamma dan beta yang
akan merepresentasikan diskretisasi dari evolusi waktu, jadi sekali lagi tiga bagian utama
dari Quantum circuit qaoa adalah satu yaitu initial trial state dalam abu-abu yang merupakan ground
state dari mixer dari state adiabatik yang dibuat dengan menerapkan gate Hadamard yang diterapkan ke setiap qubit, dua
evolusi fungsi biaya yang sudah kita miliki dalam ungu tua dan tiga evolusi di bawah mixer
hamiltonian yang belum kita bahas dalam ungu muda, sekarang hamiltonian awal kita disebut
mixer karena ground state-nya adalah superposisi dari semua bit string yang mungkin menarik, sehingga
memaksakan campuran dari semua solusi yang mungkin di awal, mixer hamiltonian adalah jumlah sederhana dari operasi Pauli X
pada setiap node graph, Qiskit memungkinkan kamu menggunakan operator mixer kustom yang berbeda jika mau tapi
untuk kasus ini kita hanya akan menggunakan yang standar, jadi sekali lagi kamu bisa melihat bahwa dengan Qiskit banyak pekerjaan
dihapuskan untuk kita membuat mixer hamiltonian dan state awal menjadi hal yang sepele, satu-satunya pekerjaan yang harus kita lakukan adalah
WEBVTT
menemukan fungsi biaya, setiap iterasi dari operator-operator ini disebut layer, layer-layer ini bisa dilihat sebagai
diskretisasi dari evolusi waktu sistem seperti yang telah dijelaskan sebelumnya, pola bergantian berasal dari
dekomposisi Trotter dan mengaproksimasi fungsi eksponensial dari matriks yang tidak komut, secara umum semakin banyak layer atau
langkah yang kita sertakan, semakin dekat kita ke evolusi waktu kontinu, jadi secara teori hasilnya akan semakin akurat
tapi untuk contoh ini kita akan mulai dengan hanya mengambil sampel dengan dua layer, ingat baik hamiltonian fungsi biaya maupun
mixer diparameterisasi, kita masih perlu mencari nilai optimal untuk gamma dan
beta, sekarang aku sadar itu banyak informasi dan kalau kamu pertama kali melihat jenis matematika ini bisa jadi membingungkan, untungnya salah satu hal keren
tentang Qiskit adalah bahwa banyak dari apa yang baru kita bahas bisa dilakukan secara otomatis tanpa usaha besar dari pengguna, bagus untuk memahami apa yang terjadi
di balik layar terutama saat kita scale up ke eksperimen yang lebih besar tapi kamu nggak harus melakukan semua pekerjaan ini
secara manual setiap saat, kita sekarang telah memetakan masalah kita ke Quantum circuit, itu butuh sedikit usaha
tapi jangan khawatir akan semakin mudah dan intuitif semakin sering kamu melakukannya, sekarang kita siap beralih ke langkah dua
mengoptimalkan circuit kita untuk Hardware, jadi sementara circuit yang baru kita buat terlihat cukup sederhana dan
berguna untuk membangun pemahaman intuitif, ingat chip kuantum nggak mengerti apa itu blok terabstraksi
ini, kita perlu mengubahnya menjadi serangkaian gate satu dan dua qubit yang native untuk hardware, dan ketika aku
bilang native maksudnya akan diperbaiki menjadi apa yang bisa langsung dilakukan pada qubit, circuit seperti itu dikatakan
ditulis dalam instruction set architecture backend yang mungkin kamu lihat disingkat sebagai circuit ISA,
modul transpiler SDK Qiskit menawarkan serangkaian transpilation pass yang bisa
melakukan berbagai transformasi circuit, kita ingin memastikan bahwa circuit kita dioptimalkan untuk tujuan
kita, ingat dari pelajaran sebelumnya bahwa proses transpilasi melibatkan beberapa langkah: memetakan
qubit dalam circuit atau variabel keputusan ke qubit fisik di perangkat, unrolling instruksi dalam
quantum circuit ke instruksi native hardware yang benar-benar dipahami backend, routing qubit mana pun
dalam circuit yang berinteraksi langsung ke qubit fisik yang berdekatan satu
sama lain, dan seperti biasa detail lebih lanjut tentang ini bisa ditemukan di situs
dokumentasi, sekarang datang langkah yang menarik di mana kita akan memilih backend mana yang akan menjalankan circuit kita, kita sebenarnya harus melakukan ini
sebelum langkah transpilasi karena transpiler mengoptimalkan secara berbeda untuk prosesor yang berbeda, ini adalah alasan lain mengapa sangat
penting bahwa Qiskit bisa mengotomatiskan begitu banyak tahap ini, kamu nggak mau harus mengoptimalkan circuit secara manual
yang bisa dilakukan tapi terkadang sulit dan memakan waktu, hanya untuk menyadari bahwa kamu sebenarnya ingin menjalankan
circuit di prosesor yang berbeda dengan properti yang berbeda dan kemudian kamu harus melakukan semua pekerjaan itu lagi, masukkan
backend pilihanmu melalui fungsi transpiler dan jangan lupa untuk menentukan level optimasi kamu,
kali ini aku memilih optimization level tiga yang merupakan level optimasi tertinggi dan paling menyeluruh
dan itu sebenarnya sudah untuk langkah dua, circuit saya ditranspilasi secara otomatis dan aku menggambarnya di sini supaya
kamu bisa melihat bagaimana ia diterjemahkan menjadi gate satu dan dua qubit, sekarang waktunya untuk langkah tiga
menjalankan circuit dengan Qiskit Primitives, sejauh ini kita telah mentranspilasi circuit dengan membiarkan parameter gamma dan
beta tetap tapi kita sebenarnya nggak bisa menjalankan circuit tanpa menentukan nilai parameter-parameter ini, dalam
workflow qaoa, parameter qaoa optimal ditemukan dalam loop optimasi iteratif di mana kita menjalankan serangkaian evaluasi circuit
dan menggunakan classical Optimizer untuk menemukan parameter beta dan gamma yang optimal, tapi kita perlu memulai
dari suatu tempat, jadi aku telah mengimplementasikan beberapa tebakan awal untuk Gamma 1 gamma 2 dan beta 1 beta 2 yaitu Pi / 2 dan Pi
masing-masing, aku juga mau kamu catat bahwa kita akan menggunakan optimizer untuk menemukan solusi yang lebih baik untuk gamma dan beta
dan karena aku hanya menghitung dua layer untuk sekarang, itu semua yang aku butuhkan tapi kalau kamu membuat circuit qaoa yang lebih akurat
kamu perlu menyertakan lebih banyak layer dan dengan demikian membutuhkan gamma dan beta yang dioptimalkan untuk setiap layer
secara berurutan, sekarang mari kita pause sebentar dan ingat pilihan kita untuk Primitives, kita punya estimator dan
sampler, mana menurut kamu yang akan kita gunakan untuk jenis pekerjaan ini? nah tidak peduli yang mana kamu
tebak, kamu sebenarnya benar, kita akan menggunakan baik estimator maupun sampler, untuk loop optimasi
awal kita akan membutuhkan estimator tapi kita akan menggunakan sampler nanti untuk membaca solusi
akhir, sekarang kita hampir siap untuk menjalankan algoritma kita, aku janji tapi sangat cepat penting untuk dicatat bahwa kamu bisa
mengirim pekerjaan kamu dengan berbagai cara yang disebut execution modes, pertama kita punya job mode, sebuah permintaan
primitive tunggal dari estimator atau sampler yang dibuat tanpa context manager, circuit dan input dikemas sebagai primitive
unified block yaitu PUB dan dikirimkan sebagai task eksekusi pada komputer
kuantum, batch mode adalah multi-job manager untuk menjalankan eksperimen secara efisien yang terdiri dari banyak
pekerjaan independen, gunakan batch mode untuk mengirimkan beberapa pekerjaan primitive secara bersamaan, session mode adalah jendela khusus
untuk menjalankan workload multi-job, ini memungkinkan pengguna premium untuk bereksperimen dengan algoritma variasional dengan cara yang lebih
dapat diprediksi dan bahkan menjalankan beberapa eksperimen secara bersamaan memanfaatkan paralelisme dari
stack, gunakan session untuk workflow iteratif dan eksperimen yang memerlukan akses khusus, untuk eksperimen qaoa
session adalah pilihan yang baik untuk dilanjutkan kalau kamu punya akses ke sana karena kamu perlu mencoba beberapa circuit untuk nilai beta dan gamma yang berbeda
oke sekarang mari kita kembali ke masalah optimasi kita, kita sudah
mendefinisikan hamiltonian fungsi biaya HC dan workflow lengkapnya adalah ini, algoritma qaoa
dimulai dengan menginisialisasi qubit dalam state superposisi lalu menerapkan ansatz dengan P layer, ia
menginisialisasi parameter gamma dan beta lalu menjalankan circuit menggunakan estimator primitive, setelah kita menghitung
nilai ekspektasi kita kemudian akan menggunakan classical Optimizer scipi yang disebut COBYLA, COBYLA
mengoptimalkan fungsi biaya secara klasik di luar QPU, setelah nilai gamma dan beta diperbarui
kita ulangi, kita akan melakukan ini sampai nilai dari fungsi biaya keseluruhan telah konvergen dan mencapai nilai terendah
WEBVTT
lalu kita akan memilih nilai gamma dan beta yang sesuai dengan nilai biaya rendah ini dan menjalankan circuit satu kali lagi
kali ini menggunakan sampler, ini adalah hasil dari aku menjalankan COBYLA Optimizer dengan tebakan awal ku, di sini kamu bisa melihat
bahwa nilai fungsi biaya selama iterasi yang dilakukan dimulai sedikit aneh, naik turun tapi
kemudian menetap di nilai yang rendah, kita akan menggunakan nilai gamma dan beta terakhir yang sesuai dengan fungsi biaya minimum ini
untuk menjalankan circuit satu kali lagi dan mengambil sampel bit string yang akan memberi kita max
cut, sekarang menggunakan nilai yang dioptimalkan untuk gamma dan beta kita akan menjalankan circuit satu kali lagi untuk menemukan
bit string terbaik yang mungkin menggunakan sampler, aku mencantumkan nilai spesifik yang aku gunakan di sini tapi ingat ketika kamu
mencoba sendiri atau bahkan hanya menjalankan ulang notebook tutorial yang sama, nilai-nilai ini mungkin sedikit berubah, sekarang kita akan menjalankan
circuit yang dioptimalkan dengan nilai-nilai ini dan menemukan solusi kandidat kita untuk masalah Max cut, kalau kamu menggunakan
session itu tidak lagi diperlukan karena kita hanya menjalankan satu pekerjaan terakhir, sekarang kita akhirnya akan melihat tahap
post-processing dan menemukan solusi akhir kita, pertama mari kita plot semua
kemungkinan kombinasi node yang telah kita konversi menjadi bit string sebagai histogram, kamu bisa langsung melihat bahwa
ketika aku menjalankannya aku menemukan empat solusi dan menyorot yang berwarna ungu yang lebih mungkin daripada solusi lainnya
bit string solusi tertinggi dan paling mungkin adalah 0 1 01, perhatikan bahwa urutan qubit
dibalik dalam plot, melihat solusi yang paling mungkin, kita mencatat bahwa node 0 dan tiga dikelompokkan bersama
dan demikian pula untuk node 1 2 dan empat, kita akhirnya bisa memplot bit string yang paling mungkin
kembali sebagai graph dan ingat bit string hanya sesuai dengan nomor node dan apakah mereka disertakan
ditandai dengan satu atau tidak disertakan ditandai dengan nol dalam pengelompokan kita, ketika kita menggambar potongan sekarang kita bisa melihat dengan mata
garis perkiraan untuk potongan terbaik yang hanya merepresentasikan pengelompokan ideal dari semua lima node yang sudah aku gambar di sini, satu
hal yang ingin aku luangkan waktu untuk membahasnya di sini adalah fakta bahwa solusi yang benar tidaklah unik
karena simetri dari graph ini ada beberapa solusi yang benar, alih-alih memiliki node 0 dan tiga berada
di dalam potongan kita bisa memiliki node 2 dan empat yang disertakan dan kamu bisa melihat bahwa yang harus aku lakukan hanyalah memutar potonganku untuk
menyertakan titik-titik baru ini, solusi lima ini tetap sama
mari kita lihat lagi histogram dan empat solusi yang paling mungkin untuk sebentar, dua solusi terakhir adalah
yang baru saja kita plot dan keduanya sama-sama benar tapi bukan hanya itu, kita juga bisa membalik pewarnaan untuk semua
solusi yang benar dan kali ini kita hanya berpikir tentang node sebagai berada di dalam versus di luar potongan, di
slide sebelumnya kita mengidentifikasi dua solusi yang benar dan unik tapi sebenarnya ada dua solusi lagi, satu sesuai dengan
kebalikan dari masing-masing dari yang itu, lihat di sini di mana aku menggambar dua solusi yang tersisa, yang aku lakukan hanyalah membalik
warna, sekarang satu-satunya masalah adalah algoritma sebenarnya tidak menemukan atau mengidentifikasi solusi keempat terakhir ini sebagai
salah satu dari empat jawaban yang paling mungkin, itu adalah kelima, solusi keempat yang diidentifikasi oleh algoritma
sebenarnya salah dan kalau kamu menggambarnya kamu akan melihat bahwa solusi itu hanya memiliki empat potongan dan karena yang lainnya
memiliki lima dan empat jelas kurang dari lima, ini jelas salah, poin di sini
adalah bahwa ini adalah algoritma aproksimasi, ini tidak sempurna dan tidak benar 100% dari waktunya, kamu memang harus
menggunakan pengetahuan dan pemahamanmu sendiri untuk sanity check solusinya, perlu ditekankan bahwa
error ini bisa muncul dari beberapa tempat, bisa dari sifat aproksimasi dari algoritma itu sendiri dan jumlah kecil
layer yang aku pilih untuk digunakan, bisa berupa error sampling yang terbatas dan ini bisa dikurangi kalau aku meningkatkan jumlah
shot dalam eksperimen ku, atau bisa berupa error readout karena solusi nyata keempat hanya berbeda satu
bit, alasan aku menunjukkan semua kemungkinan ini adalah karena inilah yang diperlukan untuk benar-benar menjadi seorang
praktisi quantum Computing, kamu perlu memahami performa hardware dan bagaimana ini bisa berkontribusi
pada jenis error tertentu dan bagaimana mengkoreksinya, tapi jangan lupakan bahwa ada
32 kemungkinan solusi bit string dan bahwa empat solusi nyata disertakan dalam lima
kandidat terbaik dan aku hanya menggunakan dua layer untuk menemukan ini, secara umum kalau aku ingin meningkatkan peluang menemukan
max cut terbaik setiap kali aku akan meningkatkan kedalaman layer, ada beberapa kehalusan dalam hal ini tapi itu untuk episode
berikutnya, sekarang aku bakal membiarkan kamu mencoba sendiri tapi kali ini kamu akan menggunakan 100
qubit, jadi kalau kita mulai dengan menggambar graph 100 qubit kita, kamu bisa melihat bahwa ini tidak lagi mudah atau bahkan mungkin
untuk menebak di mana max cut akan terjadi hanya dengan melihat, terlalu banyak kemungkinan untuk bisa memilihnya secara manual tapi
menyelesaikan masalah ini menggunakan qaoa masih sangat bisa dilakukan dan kamu bisa mengikuti workflow yang persis sama yang kita gunakan untuk 5
qubit, aku mau mengirimmu pergi sendiri dan menugaskanmu untuk mencoba melakukan eksperimen ini tapi sebelum aku melakukannya mari
meringkas, ingat bahwa enam langkah dari setiap pekerjaan qaoa adalah sebagai berikut, satu mendefinisikan
hamiltonian biaya sedemikian rupa sehingga ground state-nya mengkodekan solusi untuk masalah optimasi, dua mendefinisikan
mixer hamiltonian, tiga membangun operator yang sesuai dengan hamiltonians yang
dieksponensiasi, empat membangun circuit yang akan terdiri dari ground state awal dari mixer dan layer bergantian
yang berulang dari fungsi biaya dan evolusi di bawah mixer hamiltonian, lima menyiapkan initial state dan
menggunakan teknik classical Computing untuk mengoptimalkan parameter, enam menjalankan circuit, mengukur bit string output
mencari solusi yang paling mungkin, sekarang beberapa hal yang perlu diperhatikan di sini
aku menggunakan optimization level tiga untuk contoh 5 qubit ku tapi mungkin itu tidak diperlukan dan jawaban yang benar tetap bisa
dikembalikan sebagian besar waktu pada level optimasi yang lebih rendah karena kedalaman circuit cukup rendah untuk kasus 5
qubit, tapi untuk 100 qubit dan kedalaman circuit yang besar kamu hampir pasti akan membutuhkan level tertinggi
optimasi untuk menemukan jawaban yang benar, perlu diingat juga bahwa salah satu bagian yang paling menantang dari workflow utility
scale yang khas adalah tahap pemetaan dan menemukan graph yang sesuai dengan topologi heavy hex IBM, kalau kamu
melakukan pekerjaan ini dari awal, di situlah kamu tidak diragukan lagi akan mencurahkan banyak waktumu, untuk saat ini bagian ini telah
WEBVTT
dilakukan untuk kamu karena itu bukan poin utama dari latihan ini tapi perlu diingat bahwa itu adalah sesuatu yang akan
diperlukan untuk dipraktikkan dan menjalankan pekerjaan berskala besar tidak selalu mudah, kita akan membahas lebih dalam
di episode 4, circuit akhir kamu tentunya akan terlihat jauh lebih berantakan daripada circuit yang berjalan di 5 qubit
tapi di sisi lain aku merasa melihat circuit ini dan melihat berapa banyak gate yang dimilikinya dan mengetahui bahwa kamu
memiliki kemampuan untuk benar-benar menjalankan ini di prosesor Quantum yang nyata itu cukup
mengesankan, dan ini adalah solusi akhirku, kamu bisa melihat bahwa algoritma ini tentu mampu mengelompokkan
node menjadi dua grup yang diduga mengidentifikasi max cut terbaik yang memisahkan mereka dari dua set menjadi
garis max cut itu sendiri adalah hal yang sepele, di mana saja warna berubah sepanjang garis yang menghubungkan node tersebut menunjukkan
di mana garis max cut harus digambar, ketika aku menjalankannya, nilai max cut yang berhasil aku capai adalah
84, jadi coba sendiri dan kasih tahu aku kalau kamu mendapat sesuatu yang serupa di kolom komentar, coba tiga layer mungkin empat, coba
mengubah bobot antara node dan lihat bagaimana itu mengubah hasilnya, ada banyak eksperimen menarik
yang bisa kita jalankan dengan qaoa, sekarang ingat tidak dijamin bahwa aku baru saja menemukan solusi terbaik yang mungkin
kita tahu itu solusi yang baik tapi untuk bersenang-senang aku tantang kamu untuk mengalahkan aku, lihat apakah kamu bisa mendapatkan sesuatu
yang lebih baik dari 84, sebagai kesimpulan qaoa adalah algoritma yang sangat dinamis
dan ada banyak heuristik dan masih banyak yang perlu dieksplorasi, ini memberikan banyak ruang untuk mempelajari hal-hal baru
tentang bidang optimasi pada umumnya, baru-baru ini ada banyak pekerjaan dalam ruang optimasi sebagaimana
dibuktikan oleh semua paper arsip yang baru-baru ini diterbitkan secara online tentang qaoa atau optimasi dan yang benar-benar
keren adalah bahwa akhirnya tidak semua paper ini adalah paper teori, para teoris sudah bekerja dan mempelajari
qaoa selama bertahun-tahun tapi sekarang para eksperimentalis mulai terlibat karena kita akhirnya punya hardware
seperti prosesor IBM yang mampu menjalankan banyak eksperimen ini, kita bergerak dari ruang imajinatif
ke dunia nyata dan itu sangat menarik, ya masih ada banyak pekerjaan yang harus dilakukan dan masih
banyak error yang perlu kita cari tahu cara mengatasinya tapi kita membuat kemajuan pesat dan kamu yang menonton
video ini kalau kamu sudah sampai sejauh ini, kamu mampu menjalankan eksperimen-eksperimen ini sendiri, silakan pergi dan coba menjalankan eksperimen
100 qubit milikmu sendiri dan kasih tahu kami bagaimana hasilnya, ikuti tutorial dan kamu akan ada di tangan yang baik dan kalau kamu
punya pertanyaan atau macet jangan khawatir, kita semua pernah merasakan itu atau punya pertanyaan yang sama ketika pertama kali mulai
belajar ini, lakukan yang terbaik, kasih tahu kami pertanyaan apa yang kamu temui dan sampai jumpa lain waktu
[Music]